non so se avete presente quante views mi
ha fatto su di te rio in generale
guardate quante quanti tutti slither io
adesso veloci della trachea no sto
scherzando in realtà non facciamo sul
serio perché mi ha rotto un po le palle
effettivamente che dopo un po che tu fai
una cosa non ho avuto più stimoli nel
giocare ha detto io però sono usciti un
sacco di altri giochi punto io che ci
sono war miti o di e pio pepe rio tra
pesi roaming avrà come stai e la cosa
[ __ ] e che non ho fatto manco mezzo
quindi possiamo farli tutti in un video
così per rievocare un po i vecchi vecchi
vecchio una serva bene del giochiamo per
scrivevo ormai io e molto simile a
slither io proverei prima questo verme
jay z arena bike cosa ho appena mangiato
un bambino cosa sto vedendo ok bene io
ero rimasto ai punti non pensavo che
dovessi mangiare tipo forte o più conto
è così prova le salve lei che grosso c'è
un grossissimo più fermi tra la propria
soul magnete li ammazzo del burqa
vaccamorta mi chiamo di foto sono
minuscoli di botto
hai visto momento [ __ ] cioè io
immagino che questa sia gente che ha
continuato a giocare all'inter io per
anni
e ora sta giocando sta roba qua come
sono forte verrà chiavo benissimo c'è un
sacco di gente alla crisi ciò che non
hanno mai perso scavato e dove la vita
del mondo
porca vacca sono grosso bene così no che
cosa cazzo me ne frega dello speed test
perché mi si è aperto lo speed test vado
veloce non me ne frega una sega di
quanto vado veloce con internet stavo
giocando sta pure vincendo ma dai ma no
non è legale mi ricordo perché ho smesso
di giocare a slittare opa che
succedevano queste cose di continuo io
morivo di continuo perché aprivo pagine
web
a caso una volta sono persino finto sul
canale dimette bild ci sono rimasto per
due o tre secondi sono stati secondi più
brutti della mia vita
no no no no no no no no è così preso
sono diventato grossissimo prendendo una
cosa minuscola va bene la mia tattica
ragazzi se ve la ricordate svizzeri o
per vincere era quella di rimanere
vicino a quelli grossi perché prima o
poi schiacciavano a da soli e io passavo
prendere i punti come una cagata così
però sempre funzionato quindi perché non
farlo anche adesso perché non ti stai
schiantando mi chiuderanno vi chiudere
momento dell'omicidio non mi chiedere
non mi chiudere nomi chiudere timori se
il cane tra poco
ma dove sono ci stanno lo schermo regalo
ma che è perché la vostra ragazza non vi
scrive che a casa libera così smette di
giocare da momento all'altro no va bene
poi morto qualcuno grazie e morto
qualcuno a casa perché la mori tu che
bonico cavata ecco che si schiatta meno
male che lancia della roba che è morto
qui godzilla va bene allora sono
abbastanza grande e il che mi rende
troppo felice ho anche preso un per due
qual è la mia cosa ho muoio sono troppo
penso che la mia cosa schiattare
qualcuno no che non muore questo gigante
malizia stancando velocissimo ma ti
schianti dobbiamo portare per me j alla
vetta regala il fatto muore qualcuno non
si sa qui però io pi e tutti a caso tra
l'altro chi l'ha ucciso non si è preso i
punti sono fatti quelli che giocano ben
superiori ti schianti schiantato l'anno
forse non è però sono chiusi no no no no
no 6 baird eccolo buono mammamia meno
male che sono un po deficienti quelli
che gioca nostro gioco tipo mac o e
grosso ed è morto che perda mia foto dei
voti come dai che palle e molto prega
tutti scemi sono tutti scemi
c'è un gatto schiacciate tutti madonna
quanti punti puoi farti i gatti tuoi
grazie perché non mi si apre la pagina
dello spirito testa adesso sarebbe per
un bel momento
come si fa sfuggire quando qualcuno ti
chiude rega non sono nè io ho sempre
chiuso gente non sono mai stato chiuso
qui non so come si fa però lo faremo
non so come non lo farei più ci sia
fotterlo
così lo [ __ ] tantissimo noi ragazzi
dire che possiamo cambiare visto che sto
gioco non fa per me a quanto pare ce n'è
un altro che si chiama di e pio che
sembra una mezza avesse non ha però
sembra che periodo mi sembra tivo allora
porco zio
ecco che non facciamo le cose per bene
cos'è sta roba più di buy bene alla
partenza sono un fortissimo tra più di
fi sono morto all'eccitazione
probabilmente come si gioca sta roba
a quanto ho capito bisogna creare delle
allora mi sa che non ho capito
bisogna creare delle cose grosse tipo
delle pagine giganti e quando qualcuno
ti tocca fuori però non capito come ma
ho capito quando qualcuno mi tocca
mentre mi sto muovendo
ok ho capito io non assorbono gli altri
quindi sto gioco non puoi assorbire gli
altri va bene devi solo diventare grosso
beccare gli altri serie con il passo
falso la band ha però può inglobare le
porco schifo sono deficiente puoi
scrivere sopra gli altri questo non
avevo capito va bene eccolo che leggo e
bellissimo mi piace un sacco non sapete
giocare solo io so se farà quello che mi
vuoi mangiare perché tutti i lodo in
europa come come che c'è la mamma laida
come ma come non è non è riuscito ma non
ho capito questi giorni fa e board via
da lì
questo non ha capito me si gioca però
vabbè sono quattro attenzione ma non c'è
nessuno quindi posso ingrandire il mio
cerchio un botto e ho rischiato tanto è
però dedicate a bellissimo mi piace
tanto e fatto bene strano
mamma mia che forte che è forte sono più
forti in questo che negli altri prova
per facilità di essere vinti campioni
possono un tardo sono lento nel cervello
sono lento madonna come ho fatto a
morire così no no no vanessa ciao bella
gnocca
sei un cubo è però credo che tu sia un
cubo gnocco però vediamo se la spunto io
invece che lei si senta signor a vanessa
non è
si fa questo è scemo sono secondo
vanessa subito dietro anche se in teoria
dovrebbe essere il contrario taglio poi
però dice merlo no posso essere così
lento nell'anima del cervello come
propria preso c'è molto competitivo
ucciso un gigante come vi sono ucciso da
solo un deficiente ha ucciso un gigante
mi sono ci sono solo subito dopo che ci
si può uccidere dal solito non lo sapevo
ecco come sono molto all'inizio
porca vacca hanno poi neanche toccare i
bordi bene buona saperti al muro la
discoteca su tizio io sono il porco zio
quindi va benissimo
posso farti fuori la voglia penso che
non abbia voglia lo morto dopo non l'ho
ucciso e mi uccide lui non mi uccide
perché non so giocare e invece sa
giocare ragazzo provando a fare la
guerra costituzio che non so chi lingue
la può sfruttare di più o di meno
io sicuramente io brutto che non assorbe
gli altri perché assorbire gli altri
questo caso sarebbe fighissimo perché tu
ti faresti un sacco di punti primo
grazie grazie a tutti gasati troppo
forte
se riesco anche a togliere un po di
punti a questo che era e che quello che
mi sta subito sotto e meglio
poverino mi sto togliendo tutto quello
che ha se rimane dentro la tua parte non
fai mai nulla
pam 25 raga sono fortissimo adesso ci
sono veramente grosso so che tutti state
sperando che io stia per scattare da un
momento all'altro lo so io perché vi
conosco invece tac che schiacciano gli
altri ciao è un perfetto
sono rimasto solo io mi piace quando vi
in quei giochi ed è una cosa molto rara
per questo mi piace 96 per c'è prova a
vedere se scappare cento anche se mi
faceva niente mi sembra ci siamo
allargati pian piano è stato fighissimo
ma ragazzi saremo al cento per cento mi
danno la gnocca
stay with cuffie per terra
direi di provare l'ultimo ragazzi che di
e pio proviamo ff.aa
connecting giusto ruba agli omicidi rosa
e sparo
scusami ma diversissimo dagli altri come
faccio a far sapere al nemico
hanno tutti la vita ma dai e come faccio
avere più vita susa to sali di livello
uccidendo se cosine qualche mese ti
colpiscono schiavi
porca vacca fa un po schifo perché c'è
uno scasso non potrà mai battere un
gigante cosa diversa invece si riferiva
lì perché se fai schifo può imbattere
tutti e male che male che male che male
perché questi preti mi seguono
porca vacca che male tra le ovunque
e vabbè che lo sta sprecando aiutano
certamente attirerà obiettiva la
rigenerazione se qualche male zerbino e
vabbè ma non lo so fai tu ma porca vacca
ma impulse nova è impossibile c'è
veramente che sarà giocabile e basta
sniper twin sono doppio che male però
che male chiamare chiamate posso
ammazzare un avversario uno solo perché
i proiettili mi seguono e i miei non
seguono una sega basta seguirmi dopo i
progetti di sé con solo bene porca volta
che brutto male che male che male
maria il wall maria occhio c'è male
questa non è proiettili però solo body
da me se mi tocca sono morto questo non
muore faccia gli altri
monumenti della rete veloce perché maria
velocissima 22 per far fuori maria puoi
mollarmi maria per cortesia e fa anche
rima che più grigia con la parte o che
male gli sta tenendo contro di me e mi
piace lo stesso ghiaccio uguale rischia
vabbè
ragazzi miei spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto basta perché ho fatto veramente
troppa roba sapete che il campione
assoluto sono soltanto io mi sembra
chiaro però che il video vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi che cola se difficilmente mi
piace anche per il comitato notizia sono
state precisate e noi ci vediamo
[Musica]